[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: All right,
thank you for coming.
Today we're delighted to have
Mr. Ulrich Boser at Google.
He is the senior fellow at the
Center for American Progress,
where he writes about
education, and founded
the Center of Science
of Learning Initiative.
He's here today to discuss
his third book, titled, "Learn
Better, Mastering the Skills
for Success in Life, Business,
and School, or How To Become an
Expert in Just About Anything."
Please join me in
welcoming Mr. Boser.
[APPLAUSE]
ULRICH BOSER: So I'm up
here because I wrote a book
on the science of learning.
And it's gotten
some nice attention,
has been featured at NPR,
and "The Atlantic," "Wired,"
"Scientific American."
And it makes a pretty
simple argument.
For a long time, we've assumed
that the ability to learn
was a matter of intelligence,
sort of raw smarts,
intellectual power, sort
of cognitive horsepower.
And this is what IQ tests are
really supposed to measure--
your ability to reason
through new problems
to acquire expertise.
But what we know
now is that we can
get much better at learning.
There's specific
tools and strategies
that allow us to
acquire expertise
at much greater rates.
And in this way, we can
think about the skill
of learning to learn, really,
as a way to artificially improve
our intelligence.
So I first got interested in
this topic as a little kid.
That's me.
And I really had a hard
time learning in school.
I was in special education.
I repeated kindergarten.
I had one experience that I
talk about in the book, where
it was a 45-minute
class in math,
and I managed to be unable
to read my own handwriting.
I cheated off my neighbor.
Eventually, I acquired some
of the skills of learning.
Some just sort came to me
as they come to many of us
over time--
started thinking about thinking.
But this is really what
sparked my interest
in learning overall.
And for the past 20
years or so on and off,
I've been writing and
researching about education.
So we're going to start a
little bit with some quizzes.
We're going to have
a lot of quizzes.
What's the capital of Australia?
So I had this
question posed to me.
And it was embarrassing.
It was like a researcher was
posing the question to me.
And I was, like, I should
know the answer to this.
And I thought Sydney first.
I was wrong.
Melbourne, I was wrong.
The answer is C, as we have some
folks here who mentioned it.
So I'm going to up
the ante a little bit
here, since you guys knew
quickly, or at least some
of you knew the answer to
the capital of Australia,
to the Immaculate Conception.
So the question here is, what
does the Immaculate Conception
revolve around?
Here, my first answer was Jesus.
I mean, that's sort of
the popular conception.
And I'll acknowledge
here at the front
that this idea is
specific to Christianity
and within a cultural context.
But it turns out that
the answer is a--
that Immaculate Conception
is all about Mary.
It's not about Jesus.
So researchers call this
the hypercorrection effect.
And what's interesting about
it is, the more confident
you are in your answer, and
then you're shown to be wrong,
the more likely you
are to have learned
and to retain that
information into the future.
And so what I find
interesting about this
is that I think a lot of
people think about learning,
and think about the brain
like it's a computer.
There's data out there.
And the data comes to you.
And maybe you process it, and
you put into little boxes.
But if that were true-- if the
brain functioned that way--
you wouldn't have a
hypercorrection effect.
I mean, errors would mean that
you're actually not learning.
But what we've seen
from something like this
is actually the more wrong
that you are, the actually more
that you learn.
And so when we
think about this--
and this kind of brings us to
this sort of first lesson--
is that learning
is sense making,
that our brain is
not like a computer
and we have to make
sense of material.
And a lot of research
makes this true.
And it also helps us think a
little bit about certain study
strategies.
So over the past 10 years, we've
seen a wealth of evidence show
that some really common
study strategies,
common tools for people to
learn, aren't that effective.
So rereading, not
that effective.
Highlighters, which we see in
office buildings and schools--
I work often in a law library.
Not only do these students
have lots of highlighters,
they have different
colored highlighters.
I really want to go to them,
and say, there's actually
no research behind those.
Underlining is the same thing.
So on the other side, what
is sort of sense making?
And examples of that is
something like self-explaining,
which is sort of really
a form of quizzing, which
is why we're going to
have a lot of quizzes
as I'm talking up here.
And this is an example.
This is a guy named Brian Ross.
He was a professor
for a long time
at the University of Illinois.
He got an opportunity to take an
Artificial Intelligence class.
And you can imagine he took
it with other undergraduates.
And he knew very immediately,
he stood out right.
He's sort of older, balding.
But he really wanted to
do well in this class.
And so what he did
was just engage
in a lot of self-explaining.
Basic idea is this--
at the end of a page, at
the end of a paragraph,
at the end of a sentence
is to explain to yourself
what exactly you're learning.
The approach shows a lot of
effectiveness in the research.
And for Brian Ross himself, he
wasn't able to code as well as
some of the other students.
They had a lot more
prior knowledge.
But he was able to
learn a lot more.
In many instances, he actually
just simply understood
a lot more than
the other students.
And when we think about
learning as sense making,
as a way of sort of
actively engaging material,
another thing makes sense
is explaining something
to other people.
So researchers
really love to name
things specific in psychology.
This is now known as
the protege effect,
and explains why explaining
something to someone else
is actually like a really
effective way to learn.
So an example of this
is Richard Feynman,
might be familiar
to many of you--
one of the most well-known,
successful physicists
in sort of the modern times.
And he once had his boss,
the Provost at Caltech,
come to him, and
was, like, look,
I'm not entirely sure sort
of how half-particles obey
this form of Dirac statistics.
And finally, he was like, OK,
I'm going to figure this out.
I'm going explain it
to a bunch of freshmen.
Comes back a few
weeks later, he's,
like, I can't actually
explain this to them.
And that means we don't
really understand it.
So I really just want to make
clear that testing yourself
is a really fantastic
way to learn.
There's a study done
by Jeff Karpicke.
And what you can see here
is you see the study once.
This is what many of
us did in college.
You get some text.
You read it once.
And then you take a test.
Repeated study, sort of the
more diligent college students--
they read the text once
and then they're, like, I
should probably read it again.
So they read it a second time.
You can see how they do.
Concept mapping might be
familiar to many of you.
But this idea that you're trying
to create relationships, so
spokes and hubs.
So we see that doesn't do quite
as well as repeated study.
And then you see
retrieval practice.
Retrieval practice is the
word that psychologists
use for this idea
that you're just
pulling things out of memory.
So what these students
did was simply
to have an open piece
of paper, and they
were told to recall the
information that they had just
read.
And as you can see,
they did much better
than the other students.
So we're going to go
here to another quiz.
This idea is related
to the first.
And the question is, do
you block your practice
or do you mix your practice?
So to put this in
another way, would you
if you are playing the piano,
do all Mozart in one day,
all Bach on the next day,
and then a little Chopin
on the third day, or
in each study session,
do you mix it up?
So in each study session,
each practice session,
do you do a little
Mozart, a little Chopin?
So I'm just going to do a
little sort of random calling.
You, what do you think--
mixed approach,
blocked approach?
AUDIENCE: Mixed approach.
ULRICH BOSER: Mixed
approach-- so mixed approach
is the correct answer.
Most students choose the
sort of blocked approach.
The reason that this
works is actually
kind of similar to
learning as sense making.
It actually prevents
you from being
too robotic in the
way that you practice.
So this brings us to
our second lesson--
got to mix it up.
For me, I found this
really fascinating.
And it gets at sort
of this bigger issue.
It's sort of doing something.
It's not learning.
You don't actually get better
simply by doing something.
For myself, a great
example is driving.
I've been driving since I'm 18.
I have not gotten any better.
Handwriting's pretty
similar to me.
I've been writing
things, write every day.
And I have not gotten better
since sort of middle school.
So I also play a
lot of basketball.
And my wife and kids were away.
And it was just
very apparent to me
that I was one of the worst guys
out on the basketball court.
So I took lessons with this guy.
He played for the Harlem
Globetrotters, name was Dwayne.
What was impressive to me
is one, I got a lot better--
not great, but a lot better,
just with like two sessions.
And it's kind of
crazy to me, because I
was, like, I've been writing
about education for, like, 20
years, and still I was sort
of skeptical about the power
of these very basic
things like feedback.
And then I started to get a lot
more into the sort of science
of learning, and was, like,
oh, I should really then use
interleaving in my own life.
It showed impressive effects.
What's remarkable about this is
that this has been documented
since, like, the 1970s.
It's been documented across
different subject areas.
It's even been documented
in basketball in a study
from 1972, with a group of
female basketball players.
But I have little kids at home.
And one of them is eight.
She's studying her
division timetables.
And you know how they come home.
And she studies an 8
timetable on one day.
She studies her nine
timestable the next week.
And it's just a
very clear example
that we really just don't do
enough to interleave, to mix up
the way that we learn.
The other thing that's
interesting about interleaving
is it one, it needs to be
in the same subject area.
If you're trying to
get better at knitting,
you're not going to interleave
with coding or diving
or whatever else
you want to learn.
But the other reason that
interleaving is so powerful
is that it allows us
to understand what's
called the "deep feature."
The deep feature is
really what you want
to learn when you're learning.
And when you vary
the surface features,
you're going to understand
what that basic idea is.
And that allows you to engage
in sort of pattern recognition.
A very simple example
of this is that you
want to learn 4 plus 4.
One way would be to do it
in mathematical notation.
You can change the surface
features pretty easily
by doing it in a word problem.
Johnny comes into a school.
He has four.
And you can see where
interleaving in that way
will produce these
much greater effects.
This is another quiz question,
a moment for you guys
to read it over.
So guesses?
So I think the key thing
is to commit to an answer.
We knew from the
hypercorrection effect
that the more that you
commit to an answer, the more
that you're actually
going to learn.
So me just sort of
randomly calling on people
isn't me being a
effort as much as we
all gain a little
bit more from this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ULRICH BOSER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] D.
ULRICH BOSER: D,
all of the above.
Right.
This is a very key
idea here, and that
is that context really matters.
This could really be
from all of the above.
And the context in
which you read that
is really going to change
the way that you're going
to understand that material.
So this gets us to
Lesson 3, you need
to think about your thinking.
And researchers
call this something
called meta-cognition.
And it kind of appears
in two different ways.
One is sort of planning.
When you're thinking about
your thinking, you're thinking,
will I understand this?
What are the goals that
I need to accomplish?
How am I actually going
to measure what I know?
And then the other is
sort of monitoring.
And it is this idea that we
are sort of-- do I really
understand this?
Does this come from
a dishwasher manual?
Or is this really
sort of from a patent?
The key thing to
understand here is
that we're all overconfident.
If you do surveys of
people, most people
say that they are above average
when it comes to driving.
Most people say that
they're above average
when it comes to looks.
Most people are
above average when
you ask them do they work
harder than their coworkers.
But we know that everyone
can't be above average.
Now, lots has been
written about the sort
of idea of overconfidence.
It's sort of like a key notion
of behavioral economics.
But when it comes
to learning, it's
really important, because
our goal is, actually,
to really understand.
And there are so many
things that we actually
think that we know, but
we don't really know.
This happens to me all the time.
It's happened to me
like once a month.
Most recently, my kids
went to Gettysburg.
And I was, like, oh, yeah,
I learned about that.
And I could maybe
get through sort
of what would be the first
paragraph on the Gettysburg
website.
But then when they asked
any reasonable question--
who was the general
for the North--
I simply had no idea.
And fluency plays
a big role in this.
The more that you're
familiar with something,
and you might think that
you know a lot about it,
but you end up not, which is
explains why a lot of people
think that they really know
how a toilet bowl works.
You spend a lot of
time on toilet bowls.
But if I were to ask--
and certainly most
people maybe here--
really explain what
the engineering that
goes behind the toilet bowl,
it's hard for most of us.
The second aspect of
metacognition is monitoring.
And it's sort of an ancillary
to the idea of feedback,
which is why Dwayne
Samuels, my baseball coach,
was so effective.
And really it's this idea
that you're actually paying
attention to what you're doing.
I don't pay enough attention
to driving, which explains
why I am not a better driver.
I clearly don't pay
enough attention
to my handwriting,
which explains why I
haven't gotten better at that.
But even just a little
bit of monitoring
can go an incredibly far way.
My favorite example here is a
guy, a neurosurgeon in Canada.
And what he did was
something very simple.
For every surgery that
he had, he would just
write down what went wrong.
So if he dropped a scalpel,
he'd make a note of it.
If he miscommunicated to a
nurse, he'd note that, too.
And he found
tremendous improvements
in his performance, not
only over the first year
that he did it, but over
a period of 10 years.
The other thing about this
type of monitoring is--
and really feedback in general--
is that it's embarrassing.
So whether I go to
see a basketball coach
and I'm in my 40s, and basically
all of his other clients
are little kids--
that's embarrassing.
I didn't actually really
tell most of the people
that I took the
basketball lessons with.
The neurosurgeon had an even--
I frankly think-- a much
more embarrassing experience.
He ended up dropping
someone's skull
during a surgery, a size of
some skull about the size
of a quarter, and then
had to go to that family
and be, like, oh,
I'm really sorry.
I dropped a piece of
your husband's skull.
And he describes
that as mortifying.
I think it helps
us understand why
we don't engage in enough
monitoring, why we don't engage
in enough feedback.
So we have another
quiz question here.
Give you guys a
moment to look at it.
Want to give it a shot?
AUDIENCE: C.
ULRICH BOSER: C-- so
more than five items.
For a long time, people believed
that C was the right answer.
A lot of early
research on this idea
was seven items, plus
or minus one or two.
It turns out that this research
that was done in the 1950s.
What researchers
know now is that it's
much closer to
three to five items.
So we're going to talk about in
this quick lesson remembering
memory.
And what we're going
to talk about first
is short-term memory.
If we're going to
go the next slide.
Looks like we're not going
to go to the next slide.
But what is important
about this idea,
short-term memory is
really, really small.
It's smaller than most people
believe that it's going to be.
So this helps us
understand why it's so
hard to remember phone numbers.
For a long time, the
telephone companies,
when they first rolled
out telephone numbers,
they did it with a mix of
address and a mix of numbers.
So you have something
like Elmwood 935.
Then the research came
out by Herbert Simon
and others, 1950s.
And they knew it's seven digits.
So this would be a
number like 472-6078.
And now it's clear that the
telephone companies realize
that short-term memory is
even shorter than that, which
is why numbers that you
really need to remember
are like 9-1-1 and 3-1-1.
So why is this so important
besides telephone numbers
is that everything you learn--
knitting, diving,
driving-- it all
goes through short-term memory.
And the thing is that
short-term memory is so short
that we can't hold a
lot in it, and this
helps us really understand a lot
of other things about learning.
It explains why educators
are so important.
You want something to
be explained in a way
that it doesn't overwhelm
short-term learning.
It explains why
checking your phone,
or visiting the internet
while you're learning,
or even engaged in a heavy
thought process doesn't work.
It also explains why
slides like these--
we should aim to
have them very clean,
because they don't
overwhelm short-term memory.
The other side of short-term
memory is long-term memory.
So you process information.
It goes into long-term memory.
And long-term memory works,
basically, on knowledge.
It works on context, on what
researchers call schemas.
And this is important
for learning,
because there is this debate
in learning whether or not
you should be able-- you
should learn any facts if we
can Google all the facts.
So if Wikipedia allows all
the information to be free,
should we learn any facts?
And long-term memory
makes it very clear
that facts are
incredibly important.
My example on this is I
can say, [SPEAKING GERMAN]..
Now, you can immediately look
all those German words up
on your phone.
But it is very hard to
actually make sense of them,
to really fluently speak
in another language,
unless you have that
basic knowledge of facts.
So really, it's
important that we
start thinking about facts
as the sort of basic building
blocks of memory--
that they are ways
for us to engage.
And really one of
the best predictors
of can you be better at physics
is your knowledge of physics.
The best way to become
better at chemistry
is simply raw knowledge
about chemistry.
When we think about
memory, there's
another concept that
becomes really important.
And that's this idea of spacing.
This is an idea that dates
back to the 19th century.
And basically, we forget.
We all forget at a
very regular rate.
And we often forget
about how much we forget.
And so there's something
called "the spacing curve."
My quiz on this is sort of
how much of this specific talk
do you think you're going
to remember tomorrow,
25%, 50%, 75%?
So sir, I'm going to I ask you.
What do you think?
Tomorrow, 24 hours
after this talk,
I ask you retrieval practice.
Was it mentioned in the talk?
What do you think
is the likelihood
that you'll recall it?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: A
reasonable likelihood.
ULRICH BOSER: A
reasonable likelihood--
so reasonable likelihood
to me sounds like 50%.
So that is the correct answer.
What's frankly hard
is that I'm up here,
and I know that by tomorrow,
you're going to forget 50%.
If you don't revisit anything
of it, within a week it's gone.
So my favorite example of this
is a guy named Roger Craig.
He comes across to spacing
research, this idea
that we forget at a
very regular rate.
This was about 10 years ago.
And he started creating
his own software,
then eventually uses
some online software,
to revisit ideas at the rate
of forgetting-- sort of right
at the edge of this curve.
We know when we're going
to forget something.
And if we revisit
that item, we're
going to remember it for longer.
So Roger Craig first
develops the software
itself, then eventually uses
an online software called Anki,
which is fantastic, if
you haven't ever used it
for this type of knowledge.
And what happens is he goes--
and the thing about Roger
Craig that is key to this story
is that he loves games.
He loves baseball, football,
and he watched "Jeopardy"
growing up with his parents.
He's like, I'm going to
use the science of learning
to get better at "Jeopardy."
Roger Craig goes on "Jeopardy"
for his very first time.
He goes to Los Angeles, and
he's there with Alex Trebek.
He does so well on
his very first time
that he wins the record
for the first day
amount of winnings on that.
He did so well that when he went
home, and was in his hotel room
that night, he was,
like, they're never
going to call me back.
I did so well on these
types of recalling
of facts that he was, like,
they're just not going
to have me on.
Now, Roger Craig
has gone back on.
He's competed
against Ken Jennings,
and he's sort of one of
the top "Jeopardy" champs.
And it is really just
using the spacing effect
to revisit knowledge
at this point of time.
And it's really
incredibly powerful.
And it doesn't really
take huge intervention.
So in my family now, we don't
do homework on Wednesday night.
One thing you can do to
space out learning more
is to, instead of doing the
homework-- my kids usually
have homework on Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday--
take that Wednesday,
slide it into Sunday.
So it's this idea of just
spacing out that learning,
allowing for that
inevitable forgetting.
Now, I'm going to admit
that this has not made
me more popular as a parent.
It sort of causes
dips in my dad stock.
But I tell my kids, you're
actually going to learn more.
It's the same amount of
time you spend studying,
but you're going to
retain it for a lot more
from this basic effect.
So Roger Craig
himself will admit
to anyone who speaks to him
that knowing the answer of who
wrote "The Bridge on the River
Kwai," isn't real learning.
It's just sort of a fact
that allowed him to do really
well on "Jeopardy."
Then the question is,
what really is expertise?
What is mastery, and how do
we really want to learn it?
I got a really interesting
idea, and there's
a bunch of really
fascinating research
on this, in that mastery,
really knowing something,
is analogies.
It's your ability to
think through in systems.
So I don't know
if any of you ever
listened to the "Car Talk"
show, but it's basically
two goofy guys, and people call
in, and say, I have a Buick,
and there's white
smoke coming out.
I have a little
audio clip of it,
but basically, it's a call-in
show for car problems.
And if you listen to the
show carefully, what they do
is crazy.
They've never seen this.
Someone calls in.
They've never met
that person before.
They don't know if
they're a reckless driver.
They don't even know if they're
a student or a senior citizen.
They've never seen
the car before.
So they don't know
does it look dingy?
They've never seen
what the problem is.
And yet they are able to
diagnose these problems time
and again.
So the question then
is, how do they do it?
They do it through analogies.
If someone calls
in with a Buick,
and they're saying
it has white smoke,
they're going through their
own mental model, saying,
have I ever worked
on Buicks before?
What's the sign of white smoke?
How does this match up with
other experiences that we have?
And so when we think
about learning,
and we think about
what we ultimately
want to do with what we learn
is to apply it in new ways,
making sure that you learn
in a systems approach,
that you learn through
analogies, that you're thinking
about compare and contrast,
is really, really crucial.
So researchers have found
this in topics like math.
This also explains
the idea of the deep
versus surface features, been
able to show it in history.
And I got kind of
excited about the idea,
and was, like, I'm not
going to take a wine class.
I don't know that
much about wine.
If you think about
wine as analogies,
I should take a
wine pairing class.
And what was
remarkable to me was
that the pairings did give me
a much richer sense of wine.
So going in, understood
and was presented me
how did the tannins relate to--
or why exactly does
sort of a fatty cheese
reduce the sort of
tannins that you'd
find in a lot of red wines?
Why do sweet wines
like a Gewurztraminer
go well with spicy food.
But this is different
than a lot of the ways
that we would usually
engage with wine.
I think a lot of
people would be,
like, I need to figure
out what is a pinot noir?
Where is a Gewurztraminer grown?
When if you really want
to use that information,
and use it in new ways,
you have to engage in what
are the patterns.
Another example of this is the
history example that I prefer.
Let's say you want
to learn about war.
You want to learn
about World War II.
You can think about why did the
Germans win in World War II?
One of the reasons,
the blitzkrieg--
by definition the
lightning attack--
was all about speed.
And then you can start
thinking about why does speed
help in wars?
One of the reasons
that the Americans lost
the war in Vietnam was
because of a lack of speed.
On the other side, the Americans
won the Revolutionary War
largely through speed.
And when you start thinking
of topics in this way,
making sure that you
learn in this way,
it makes for a richer
sense of learning.
I ended up spending some time
with an ER doctor at USF.
And he's sort of a real
expert on problem solving.
This is his thing.
And I watched him.
This was at a medical
school conference,
but someone brought in a case.
And it was a rare case.
It was a man spitting up blood.
And he gave some advice around
what is good problem solving.
So one thing that
he said was, you
need a one-sentence
description of the issue.
You want something that
you're able to Google.
Another bit of advice
that I thought was great
was that you need to update
your background knowledge.
So go visit the Wikipedia site.
Make sure your
deep knowledge is--
your long-term memory
is rich enough.
No but the other
thing that ultimately
is problem solving, at least
in this medical context--
and really, when you think
about it, any form of problem
solving-- it's a form
of pattern recognition.
So he has in his mind
different kinds of scripts,
mental models of diseases.
And he is trying to match that
information, basically a form
of analogical thinking,
to match that information
with the information of the
patient that's in front of him.
So we're going to go to the sort
of final lesson, as it were.
And what then becomes
really important
is the process of reviewing,
of reflecting, of revisiting.
So here's another
quiz question for us.
And the question is,
should a speaker,
whether it's me or an educator--
how long of a pause
should they give
in a speech to allow people
to dwell on a big idea?
So should they leave
one second, two seconds,
or more than three seconds?
So how long should
the pauses be when
a speaker is asking an important
question, one second, two
seconds, or more
than three seconds?
I'm going to ask you.
What do you think?
No, here in the front.
OK, we're going to go to
someone else, with the glasses.
AUDIENCE: More
than three seconds.
ULRICH BOSER: More
Let's just say that the research
study dates back to the 1980s,
is actually between
three to five seconds.
What's remarkable is that three
to five seconds is actually
a pretty long time.
Now, I give this
presentation a lot.
And I talk about this quiz
item, but I actually don't even
obey by the research itself.
I have not waited three to five
seconds, though I should have,
because for the presenter, it's
actually kind of uncomfortable.
It's a good chunk of time.
But when you look at really
good speakers, speakers
who are much better than
me, like Barack Obama,
if you watch him,
he speaks so slowly.
And the idea there is
just people need time
to digest this information.
Now at first glance, it seems
like it's about working memory.
And to a degree, it is.
But there's another
thing happening here,
and that is we often think that
our thoughts and our emotions
are separate, or that our
body and reason are separate.
But they're very connected.
And so we need time to reflect.
So another way to
think about this
is, if I had two cell phones,
and they're the same cell
phone--
this is a nice study
that was done once--
and I have one of
them the finger,
and then I wave at the
same other cell phone,
I will think that the
first cell phone--
even though it's the
same cell phone--
is a much worse cell phone.
And so what happens is, my hand
giving my phone the finger--
it did the thinking.
My hand did the thinking.
And then I used that
thinking, and engaged in it.
So this is an incredible
thing when you think about it.
Our hands aren't
supposed to think.
Our bodies aren't
supposed to change the way
that we reason in this way.
And yet they do.
And this explains-- and I
think in other contexts,
we kind of know this idea.
So in the creativity space--
and people love to
talk about that,
like you were in
the shower and you
had that moment of recognition.
But we need, then, the same
thing in the learning space.
We need these times to reflect.
We need these times to
process this information,
and allow, in many
ways, our emotions
to become attached to them.
The other aspect of reflection--
and we can do this ourselves,
this form of reflection.
So some of it explains you
know why we want safety
when we're learning.
We see this is really
important in schools.
This also explains why
moments of solitude
can be really
important for learning.
It also explains why just
even writing about something
is a very powerful way to learn.
And we see experts who
really hone on getting better
at their craft.
So Pat Metheny is a
famous jazz guitarist.
Some of you might be
familiar with him--
really one of the world's best.
And after every
concert, he'll just
spend a good chunk
of time just writing
about what worked,
what didn't work,
engaging in this
type of reflection.
And the other thing about
this type of reflection
is that it also allows
us to check our work.
This allows us to engage in
kind of the meta-cognition
and make sure that
we're not too confident.
What's weird about
giving this type of talk
is that the messages that
they often really boil down to
are not ones that I think
many people want to hear.
So one of them is that
learning isn't really fun.
And when you see a
lot of games that
promise you can learn
secretly, that learning
is going to be fun, and
the research actually
suggests that it's
the other way around.
So one of the reasons that
interleaving is a powerful way
to learn is that
it actually makes
learning a little bit harder.
And I think an alternative
way to think about this is
a math professor at Princeton.
And I was talking with him.
And he was, like,
yeah, students today
are always saying
learning is fun.
The much better way to thinking
about it is that math is fun,
and that's what makes it hard--
excuse me, math is hard, and
that's what makes it fun.
So that you're engaging in
these types of difficulties
is actually what
makes it enjoyable.
And to give other
examples of the way
that this type of active
sort of harder processing--
it's also just so easy to slip
in these more comfortable ways,
whether we're using
highlighters or rereading.
I had this experience myself
a few weeks ago, where
I was preparing for a talk.
And I like had my
notes in front of me.
And I was just like, I
really wanted these notes.
And I kept basically
rereading them.
And they were comfortable to me.
It was a topic I hadn't
spoken about a lot.
And it was really the
opposite of better learning.
I'm much better off putting
the material away, and engaging
in that way.
Another way to
think about this is
sort of repeat-backs,
sort of a management tool.
But it's essentially a
form of active learning.
I've done it now
often with my wife.
If you give someone
some instructions,
and if they're more
complicated instructions,
you want then to repeat that
information back to you.
That's another way
of sort of engaging
this form of active learning.
I think the other thing
that's sort of the key theme
here is, forgetting can
really be your friend.
We often think that
forgetting works against us.
But forgetting actually allows
us new forms of perspective.
It allows us to engage
in more systems thinking.
The key thing to also
understand about forgetting--
and this is a weird
concept to understand--
is that you actually
don't really forget.
There are some fun studies
on this, that if I go to you
and say, can you remember your
high school locker number,
I think most people
would be, like, no, I
can't remember that.
But if I show you four options,
and of those, one of them
is your high school
locker number,
far more than one might
guess, and certainly
a lot more than
average, you're actually
able to identify that number.
So the question is, if you are
able to remember everything,
how do you actually
remember something?
And to do that,
it's the retrieval.
It's pulling things
out of memory
that makes them more available.
And this explains why
these more active types
of learning, whether it's
explaining to yourself
or explaining to someone
else, can be so effective.
They allow you to see
these types of connections.
But then again, they
allow you to have
things sort of top of mind.
They allow you to
exist with them.
And I guess my parting
thought in this regard
is always, always
look for patterns.
It's so easy to look for this
very specific bit of detail.
So if you're learning
about oceans as an example,
you'd want to know what's
the temperature of the ocean.
But if you're engaging in
these types of analogies,
you're starting to think--
or these types of
systems thinking-- you're
going to say to yourself,
what happens when
the water temperature goes up?
One of the things that happens
is more vapor is produced.
This helps us understand
why climate change can
be so dangerous, because some
of the storms are more terrible.
This also helps us,
then, understand
why sea levels are rising,
because the relationship
between heat and water
is such that water
expands as it grows bigger.
Analogies, though,
are difficult.
And when you're using analogies,
using this type of systems
thinking, you want to have
analogies that you know well,
so the analogy of it cuts like
a knife works, because we're all
pretty familiar with knives.
And analogies in
this same regard
is that if you're explaining
an idea to someone else--
sort of like you might Uber
for kindergarten or Uber
for cooking--
you're using an analogy that
all of us are familiar with.
And then the reverse side
is that these analogies that
don't work are either
sort of quiz problems,
or they're just plainly funny.
And I'll leave you with
that thought, which
is what do Barack Obama and Mt.
Kilimanjaro have in common?
It turns out to be Africa.
So with that, I'm going
to thank you again
for taking the time to come out
here today and listen to this.
And thank you again.
[APPLAUSE]